alright
[Music]
the hector cell guides me with the
headlines for today friday october 23rd
this morning the power is back on the
ritz hotel in las vegas after the
property suffered a two hour blackout
last night firefighters and police
evacuated  most of the people
who were in this hotel still do not
know the reason why this cut arose
the coronavirus forced the nfl to change
the game schedule of the rangers
scheduled for this sunday the
game against time day will be now  at
one o'clock on sunday afternoon 3 round was
put on a cadiz roster
while 5 more players from the
team's offensive line went home
after practice on wednesday
as a precaution the raiders continue to
monitor this situation
the only resort that  was
closed on the strip
will finally reopen its doors
next week cromwell announced his
return for october 29
however the hotel and the gambling hall  as they
will be exclusively for people over 21
years old but the restaurant will now be
available to people from all
cities
and now we move on to the weather forecast
we will have a hot Friday
hovering around 80 degrees for today
however we will see a drop in
temperatures and we will be on  Turning 50 is due
on Monday, very cold is expected
for next week, have a happy
Friday, I am Héctor Mejía and this was
your brief informative about teaching in
Spanish
[Music]